[Music]
morning everybody it's seven o'clock
thank you for watching us from whistler
to wigan really a lunch date you won't
want to miss boris johnson and zakir
stammer face to face at prime minister's
questions with strong views over the
jimmy sample slur from both sides of the
house including apparently the speaker's
chair we'll bring it to you live at noon
and in a few minutes we're joined by the
health minister edward argo we'll get
his thoughts too on the nhs backlog
we'll also speak to labour's pat fadden
and the mayor of london city khan how
will we fit it all in it's wednesday the
9th of february
head to head the prime minister prepares
to face the labour leader this lunch
time after a warning from the speaker
that words have consequences in the wake
of the savile slur
ships in the night russia claims
warships heading to the black sea are on
a drill we'll ask the ukrainian
ambassador if he believes that
he's one of our better players west
ham's manager defends his decision to
use kurt zuma who booted his cat around
his kitchen as fans show their anger
agatha christie will reveal the
astonishing accusations from the
footballers wives locked in a court
battle
is today the day that team gb gets off
the mark in the winter games charlotte
banks is on her snowboard this hour
racing for a
medal adele wins big at the brits with
three awards but it's dave who set the
audience alight winning the prize for
best hip hop and grime
also on the programme for you this
morning sent from the wild will take you
through some of the wildlife photographs
of the year
and speak to a winning photographer
and the new cool runnings i'm going to
be joined a little later by the jamaican
bobsleigh team uh hoping to uh sprint
legend uh usain bolt can inspire them to
victory in beijing i'm going to have
another go at that in the next hour
[Music]
i was slightly distracted because the
minister is uh here good morning thanks
for joining us this morning thanks for
coming in uh let's talk waiting list of
shots to start with should we um
they are going to perhaps double over
the next two years until march of
2024 your manifesto said that you were
going to be there when patients needed
you now what happened um the pandemic
happened is the short answer okay we
knew that we had a challenge with
waiting lists before the pandemic that's
why our manifesto commitment was clear
but we've had two years of huge
disruption
to our nhs as it both tackled the
pandemic but also as it wasn't able to
do as many routine or normal procedures
as it normally would and that figure you
talked about about the waiting list
going up there's about well there's just
around six million people on the waiting
list there's around eight and a half
million
who we would normally expect to have
come forward over the past two years who
haven't and therefore we've got to make
an assessment that many of them will now
start coming forward so we should expect
here as the secretary of state says that
is going up before we can bring it down
but we've set out the plan to do that um
this week one in 10 people presently on
an nhs waiting list right now
it's actually it's around one in nine
people on the on the waiting list i'd
always straight with you and your
viewers okay about this i think it's one
in five in wales that's a huge figure
and every one of those people will
understandably
be concerned they'll either be in pain
or they'll be and somebody anxious about
wanting to find out about 75
of those in the on the waiting list are
not on the waiting list for actual
treatment they're on it for things like
diagnostic tests in the large part and
they will be people who don't know um
what their situation so understanding
they'll be very anxious that's why we're
investing heavily in diagnostics because
people want to know whether they're okay
or whether they do need to have
treatment and people can move around the
country to have treatment that has been
the case for some time but people
haven't been doing that obviously
because of the pandemic but even before
that they weren't so how do they find
out how to do that well there's a number
of
ways we're doing that first one and i
think
my boss secretary of state i think was
on with you earlier he was this week my
planned care is one of those
one of those mechanisms online people
being able to see waiting times at
different you just lost
to the nhs you'll be able to we're
developing that uh that system as we
speak so it's not only yet not there yet
he wanted to be open with people that's
a key part of the plan
but equally as part of that plan we're
working with the nhs with a national
coordination team who will work with
clinicians who will be able to give
people more information and options
where they may want to stay local but
there may be a longer wait for that
particular specialty in their hospital
but they may be able to go around the
country the nhs is putting in place that
plan to help move people around with
things like transport but it's not but
also no it's not there the secretary of
state set out the plan for this and that
will come on stream later this year
it's a part of that plan we've already
started though i know there was a lot of
speculation on monday saying well where
is the plan does this mean that we're
delaying helping people no it doesn't
because we've already announced for
example the diagnostic centers
diagnostic hubs which are already up and
running and i think 60 or 70 different
places
so we haven't waited but this plan sets
out that longer term approach and
crucially some of those targets and
those trajectories for trying to bring
that waiting list back down
march 2024 is when we can see the
waiting list start to fall that's
perilously closed for a government given
that the election is in may of that year
well i think kay what's important with
this plan and you're sitting you're
seeing some of the comments i think from
some of the nhs leaders who've commented
on it is yes it's ambitious it wants to
bring those waiting lists down because
every person on that
waiting list every statistic on that
waiting this is a real person with
health concerns but we've got to be
realistic about this we've got to be
honest with people
about the scale of that challenge um and
uh and the impact that will have both on
workload and on workforce so what we've
set is is what we think is ambitious but
realistic as a way to bring that waiting
list down and we want to be straight
with people about it okay your ultimate
boss uh prime minister's questions later
on today is he going to apologize for
what he said about uh kyocerma by the
prime minister it's now time the prime
minister kaye has been um frankly he's
clarified what he was talking about i
know colleagues of mine have been on had
this conversation with you in recent
days he's clarified that he was talking
about
circa in the context of his leadership
role the c
cps
just as quite rightly shakir holds him
to account his leadership role over the
government that doesn't mean personal
responsibility for individual decisions
but that's the context the prime
minister has clarified that okay i'll
just take it and i'll be honest with you
i suspect that's that's what you will
hear from the prime minister yeah do i
take it from me take it from the speaker
this is what he said yesterday
these sorts of comments only inflame
opinions and generate disregard for the
house and it is not acceptable our words
have consequences and we should always
be mindful of that fight
and he specifically slowed the leader of
the opposition didn't he well you heard
sir lindsay there they speak about words
having consequences they do and i think
all politicians all of us in the public
eye whether in media and politics and a
whole range of um sort of indeed
individuals on things like twitter and
need to think carefully about the words
we use i have no doubt that
after i come off this morning media
round i will go back to my own box and i
will receive threats and abuse that's
sadly what happens it shouldn't happen i
think everyone needs to reflect
carefully
those trolls are not the prime ministers
no i think everyone's speaking from the
district i think everyone needs to
reflect specifically
he's specifically he said well the prime
minister's clarified didn't either
the prime minister has clarified for you
what you said here we go
this leader of the opposition a former
director of public prosecutions mr
speaker
he spent most of his time prosecuting
journalists and failing to prosecute
jimmy savile he he he was talking about
him not the position that he holds but
the prime minister's been clear that and
they clarified that i think on a few
days afterwards that he was referring to
him and he said he in the context of his
role as leader of an organization not
just
from what we just heard that's what the
prime minister has been and they're
really clarified by that and you believe
the prime minister do you think that's
do you think that let's just
okay let's just um let's just remind our
viewers um exactly what he said uh in
blackpool when he was clarifying the
situation
i'm talking not about uh the leader of
the opposition's personal
um record when he was uh when he was dpp
uh and i and i totally understand that
he had nothing to do
personally with those decisions
he was talking about the leader of the
opposition i just played you this went
in the context of his leadership with
the dpp and he had nothing personally do
with those decisions so about that it
wasn't a personal point he was making as
the prime minister made clear and as and
kier quite rightly had said he when he
was dpp he took responsibility for the
successes and the failures he was
totally right about that just as he's
right say the prime minister
as leader of the government takes
responsibility for all aspects of what
happens in government someone who was by
the prime minister's side for 12 years
resigned
as a direct result
of what the prime minister did and did
not apologize talking about meniere
merza of course she wrote in her letter
there was no fair or reasonable basis
for the assertion this was not the
normal cut and thrust of politics it was
an inappropriate and partisan reference
to a horrendous case of child sex abuse
she decided to resign over it well i
worked with munir in the past when she
was at city hall i'm in her previous
role and i have great respect for munir
i'm very sorry to see her girl i think
she's a lady of great integrity and gay
great ability i'm sorry to see her go
but as i say i saw the prime minister's
clarification that it was clear that he
was referring to
secure in the context of leader of an
organization not personally i accept
that clarification but i would come back
to find that mate which is of course we
do all need to be uh mindful of the
language we use as i always seek to be
when i come on your show and i speak at
the dispatch and which we appreciate of
course but julian smith tobias ellwood
robert lagan city khan who's on later on
nicholas sturgeon david lammy ed davey
the wife of the husband forgive me of
joe cox who who was murdered all saying
that words have consequences the prime
minister why is it so hard for him to
apologize well i think you're right say
words have consequences and i think
that's why it was right the prime
minister clarified what he meant and was
very clear in that clarification i think
it was clear that he was not suggesting
any personal involvement by care i think
it's important that he made that
clarification i'm pleased that he did
make that clarification but i think he
was right to make it so
why is sorry such a difficult word for
this prime minister well i think this
prime minister has set out his his
position quickly he's clarified it he's
explained what he meant um with those
remarks he explained very clearly it
wasn't a personal
reference and i think that um that that
is an appropriate way for him to have
moved things forward
let's talk very briefly about this mini
shuffle reshuffle we disappointed you
weren't bumped up okay
javid's job
okay i've been um minister of state of
health i think i'm the longest serving
minister of state of health in 20 years
i think now alfred
and i i suspect if i was in another role
i wouldn't get the opportunity so
frequently to come on your on your
program and do the morning round now
it's a huge privilege for me to be
minister of state health particularly
during a pandemic i've had the
opportunity it's very difficult times
and you and i have spoken on many
occasions but to work with some amazing
um people i like everyone else serve
wherever i'm asked to do my best for my
country in that context and it's been a
huge privilege and continues to be a
huge privilege to work with the nhs and
drive forward
our plans for the recovery of waiting
lists and supporter nhs have you set
your wedding date yet
um
we might well have done kate have you
told have you told her obviously don't
break it to the rest of the world before
you've told your fiance we might well
have done later this year oh lovely okay
i'll wait for my invite lovely to see
you thank you very much indeed for
joining us thank you a quick look at the
front pages of the papers this morning
telegraph to start with uh quotes the
health secretary sanji javid warning
that nhs waiting lists won't begin to
get shorter until at least 2024.
the time says some conservative mps
believe the prime minister plans to
clear the nhs backlog
aren't ambitious enough
and the mail also suggesting the
government could move faster given that
12 billion pounds is expected to be
generated by the national insurance hike
in april
the express also leading on this story
highlighting how 10 million patients
have yet to be treated for other
conditions due to difficulties brought
on by covid
according to the eye a million more
children look set to go hungry as the
cost of living crisis continues the
mirror carries the words of bp's chief
financial officer who insists that the
company has more money than it knows
what to do with
and the guardian reports on a group of
conservative mps who are accused of
trying to derail the government's green
agenda and the metro has the latest on
the court case involving footballers
wives rebecca vardy and colleen rooney
a reminder that tomorrow at 9am joined
in the studio by the education secretary
nadim zahawi who will be answering your
questions you can tweet questions if you
would like to there you go ask the
education secretary at sky dot uk
six russian warships are sailing to the
black sea for naval drills according to
the interfax news agency citing russia's
defense ministry three of the ships have
passed through turkey straits reuters
news agency reports the other three are
expected to pass today citing turkish
sources russia has masked more than a
hundred thousand troops near its border
with ukraine it denies any plans to
invade
at 9 20 speaking to the ukrainian
ambassador to the uk
still to come on the programme for you a
frozen lake in italy we'll speak to the
people's choice award winner in the
wildlife photography of the year
competition
have changes to the highway code
improved conditions for cyclists or made
them worse
and the mayor of london
is pledging access to mentor for all
young people who need it he'll be
joining us in the studio
yesterday we brought you the news that a
west ham player had apologized after
video emerged of him kicking and
slapping his pet cat it's now emerged
that kurt zuma faces a possible police
inquiry into the footage
well last night kurt zuma was selected
and played for his club west ham
against watford and fans made their
thoughts very clear singing rspca and
when the player was filed chanting that
he knew how his cat felt
well this is what some of the papers are
saying how could they pick him as the
headline on the back page of the daily
mail this morning it says west ham have
been criticised for selecting the player
for last night's game
the times that says west ham's climb
into the top four was tainted by the
decision to play curt zuma
and the telegraph says curt zuma was
booed by both sets of fans
last night
melania is standing by for us in the
newsroom hi molina good morning what
happens now
hi kay well you do have to wonder if
west ham could have just let kurt zuma
sit this game out considering the
widespread outrage over his actions he
played just 24 hours after this video
emerged of him
dropping and kicking his pet cat um and
when he was asked uh before the game
about whether
kurt zuma's actions played any dis you
know influence on his decision to
include him in the match david moyes the
boss
of the club said that while he was an
animal lover no because he was one of
their better players take a listen to
what he had to say
i'm really disappointed
and uh the club of taking all the
actions that they can do at the moment
and they're they're you know working on
that behind the scenes
my job is to try and pick a team and
pick the best team which gives me the
best chance at west ham and kurt was
part of that team
now the club did
condemn his actions and said that they
will deal with it internally but the
decision to include zuma was widely
condemned one of those was wild
representative chris packham who said
that
tonight some humans decided it was more
important to allow a man who kicks
defenseless fragile animals the
opportunity to kick a ball for
entertainment zuma did issue an apology
for his actions saying there was an
isolated incident so did his brother who
filmed the entire thing but we do know
now that essex police are conducting as
they say urgent inquiries and they're
also liaising with the rspca about it
rspca is saying they received dozens of
complaints about this over social media
okay thank you
thanks a lot
uh there was a happier outcome last
night for a cat who held up play at
hillsborough
[Applause]
what's going on there poor cat yeah
running after a cat that's never going
to end well is it the match between
sheffield wednesday and wigan was halted
temporarily after the cat wandered onto
the pitch it was left to the wigan
player jason kerr to scoop it up
and
finally
yay can i have a stroke yeah there we go
he doesn't know what to do there we go
escort it off the field of play he's got
his claws out and everything we've got
some really big cats to come very
shortly on the programme for you now if
you thought the incredible wagatha
christie saga was put to bed in 2019 you
were very wrong this of course was that
clash between rebecca vardy and colleen
rooney after rooney accused the former
of leaking private information about
rebecca who denies the allegations
yesterday the high court witnessed some
explosive and explicit messages sent
from rebecca vardy
to her agent caroline watts about wayne
and colleen and mrs watt has been put
under the spotlight herself after
admitting to leaking information to the
press about colleen but when asked for
further evidence ms watts said that
regrettably
she dropped her phone
in the north sea
okay straight face again everybody u.s
officials have arrested a rapper and her
partner in connection with the seizure
of 3.6 billion dollars worth of bitcoin
heather morgan who goes by the name of
razel khan and her husband ilya
lichtenstein are accused of attempting
to launder 119
705 bitcoins after a hacker attacked the
bitfinex cryptocurrency exchange in
2016. the funds were worth 71 million
dollars at the time but are now worth
more than four and a half billion
dollars
and a fire has broken out at an
apartment complex under construction in
oklahoma city it's been described as
extremely large and involving rubberized
roofing material but that does not go
out well with water is what apparently
the fire service has said no injuries
have currently been reported thankfully
canada's most important border crossing
with the united states has been blocked
by truckers protesting about kovid rules
the bridge between detroit and windsor
ontario carries a quarter of all trade
between the two countries the protests
began in ottawa and have been causing
disruption for 12 days
well yet to win a medal in beijing team
gb hoping to change that today as
charlotte banks goes for gold in the
snowboard cross the current world
champion set the second fastest time in
qualifying and she is now through to the
quarter-finals which is fantastic our
sports correspondent tom palmenta is at
the snow center in hemel hempstead for
us this morning um hi tom tell us more
about what we might be hoping for
well the beijing games hasn't yet
delivered a medal for team gb but today
we're hoping thinking that it could just
be the day because it is all about the
snowboard cross and
this is the slope in hamel hempstead
which is charlotte banks's home course
and coming down here in the pink hat is
amy fuller
good morning good morning amy how are
you doing you were of course at sochi in
the winter games but all eyes are on
charlotte is she going to do something
today that delivers a medal for team gb
my fingers and my toes are crossed she's
definitely got the potential she's had
an amazing run up to this olympic games
eight podiums four of them gold it is
hers to lose now she hasn't always
represented team gb because she moved to
france when she was four
was born here in hema hempstead but
represented france at previous winter
games and has now switched because she
felt that team gb just was a better
place for her yeah i think the amount of
money that's been injected through uk
sport and the national lottery it's a
really good time for snow sports
throughout the last games we've seen
huge success 2014 jenny jones bronze
medal and then again billy morgan in
2018 so snow sports in a really good
place and charlotte's got the experience
2014 she was young inexperienced we look
at 2018 and this is where border cross
is really really interesting quite
literally anything can happen
unfortunately she fell over there
so now it's got to be her time some
people draw the comparison with bmx in
the summer games because it's a
fast-paced race where
literally anything can go wrong at any
moment yeah i think the success of kai
white and bethany shriva in the summer
if you are to take a bmx track stick at
altitude cover it in snow you've got a
series of moguls bank turns and it is
the fastest man or woman to the bottom
so in terms of it being a spectator
sport if you like that make sure you put
it on right now because you're going to
be on the edge of your seat and we know
that she's through to the semi-finals
and the quarter the actual final itself
will happen at around quarter to eight
this morning everything crossed as you
say is she gonna do it
i think she is you know i spoke to her
two weeks ago i got a little intel on
her olympic routine so a lot of
snowboarders got the mountain they get
pumped up you know it really revved up
but charlotte's got a totally different
approach she's very zen in between her
runs so right now you can imagine her
she's at the top of the course and she's
quite literally chilling reading a book
drinking green tea i say that's the way
amy thanks for joining us live on sky
news breakfast this morning it's okay
it's about the green tea reading a book
between the races but all eyes on
charlotte banks a lot of people here
willing her towards the podium at course
to wait okay lovely thanks very much
thanks a lot of course we'll bring that
to you live here on sky news it's only
uh
mid-february and that is already the
best entrance by a guest by a country
mile this year let's take a look at some
of the best pictures making the morning
papers for you the guardian has this
great image of the heroes parade for
senegal's football squad who was
celebrating africa cup of nations glory
how cool is that picture the forgotten
man the telegraph shows us the moment
lithuania's prime minister missed the
door to downing street and boris johnson
had to come out to fetch you know here
or maybe
she thinks maybe she thinks the leader
lives at number 11.
see what i did there and the daily mail
has this shot of the olympic ski jump in
beijing that looks like it's in a
dystopian hellscape as it's built in the
middle of a repurposed steel mill can
you believe it and the times has this
show of stars making a fleeting
appearance during a moment of clear sky
taken from the top of the cobbler in
argyll and butte gorgeous
hello again everybody our top stories
for you this morning the health minister
edward argo has told this programme that
everyone needs to think more carefully
about their words but he says boris
johnson won't apologize for his jimmy
staple comments at pmq's today
six russian warships sailing to the
black sea for naval drills as moscow
continues to flex its military might on
ukraine's border
and west ham's manager has defended his
decision to play kurt zuma who booted
his cat around his kitchen as fans show
their anger
it's said to be another high octane
prime minister's questions today but the
health minister edward argher told me a
few minutes ago that there won't be an
apology from boris johnson in the
commons he said the pm had already
clarified his comments about jimmy
savile but it was time for everyone to
take care over their words
all politicians all of us in the public
eye whether in media and politics and a
whole range of um sorts of indeed
individuals on things like twitter and
need to think carefully about the words
we use i have no doubt that
after i come off this morning media
round i will go back to my own box and i
will receive threats and abuse that's
sadly what happens it shouldn't happen i
think everyone needs to reflect
carefully is he going to apologize for
what he said about uh kia stomach by the
prime minister it's now time the prime
minister kaye has been um frankly he's
clarified what he was talking about i
know colleagues of mine have been on had
this conversation with you in recent
days he's clarified that he was talking
about
circa in the context of his leadership
role at the c uh cps um just as quite
rightly shakira holds him to account for
his leadership role over the government
that doesn't mean personal
responsibility for individual decisions
but that's the context the prime
minister has clarified that okay let's
just take it from and i'll be honest
with you i suspect that's that's what
you will hear from the prime minister
[Music]
well joining us now former pensions
minister baroness altman hello t thank
you for joining us on the programme this
morning lots to talk to you about but i
wonder if we could just start with that
should the prime minister apologize at
the dispatch box given that's where he
um first came up with a slur
my own view is absolutely he should
absolutely he should
um and i remember during my time as
minister that uh i
was hauled over the coals
for apologizing for something i said
which i felt was perhaps a little bit uh
misleading or
you know said something that wasn't
quite right
and i was told ministers don't apologize
and i still do not understand
why
if
one has said something that has been
maybe taken the wrong way or caused
offence even if you didn't mean to do
that
you can't just say sorry
you know it's what we teach our children
in the sake of for the sake of family
harmony even if you don't really think
what you said was wrong
when you get to the point where
everything is all stoked up you just
need to say i'm sorry for the sake of
family harmony
and we've got a country here
that that is really clearly there are
some uh angers that people are boiling
over there's there's
you know a real
feeling of tension across the country
and if an apology can calm things down
why would you not do that as a leader of
the country
why do you think he won't
i i must admit that i find it really
truly puzzling
because
uh i don't think that he meant
to cause the kind of
hatred and vitriol that has been
apparently stoked up by this
and i do understand actually that
uh zakir stama was the leader of
of the cps at the time
uh but we all know he was not personally
involved in in the decision uh and sakia
starmer at the time
apologized and took responsibility
uh for being the leader of
an office where mistakes were made
i think that's usually what one would
expect
somebody at the top to do
if they believe that people
have felt if you like let down or
done something that
would be helped
by an apology
totally understand i want to
trouble you for a couple of thoughts on
pensions first of all mps uh voting
through a pension rise that will be
outstripped by inflation yesterday and
the chancellor's removed the triple lock
thoughts on that
well
i was leading a rebellion in the house
of lords and we put a very reasonable
compromise
to the government that would allow
the keeping of the earnings link in the
triple lock it's the earnings protection
that has been abandoned
and has caused so much problem
and unfortunately mps in the commons
voted against that
it would have given a
much fairer increase to both
the state pension
and what's called the pension credit
which is the top-up that the poorest
pensioners live on which has always been
increased in line with earnings and
suddenly because
earnings rose very fast during the
pandemic
that the link was dropped i think that
was a terrible decision
i would love to see the government go
back on its
decision but i don't think there's any
chance of that and practically it's
probably too late to change the systems
but pensioners are going to struggle the
poorest pensioners in particular
have been shortchanged they were
promised the protection that has been
taken away
and i just don't agree with that policy
i'm afraid
and
i also wonder if you had a thought on
suggestions from labour that a windfall
tax would be the right way forward for
some of these oil companies in order to
try to bring down energy bills for those
that need it most the flip side to that
is the government is saying that a lot
of pension funds um are invest
in things like bp shell et cetera et
cetera et cetera so it could impact on
pensioners in that direction do you
think that's a reasonable argument
well
i think one can go a little bit too far
on the issue of um
worrying about whether or not you should
impose taxation policy because of what's
happening in pension funds but i do
think that
one has to be careful not to
take away the ability of
our biggest energy companies to invest
in clean energy i
i think that the move to net zero is
right i hope the government does not
roll back on that and i don't
see signs yet that the government is
doing that although there is some
pressure trying to encourage that
and there are a lot of companies that
have done extraordinarily well out of
both the pandemic
and the central bank policies of
creating new money which has
inflated asset prices and and shares and
property
so you know there is a case for saying
that if you need to raise large sums in
taxation
one should look to
raise that from a broader base
which has benefited
rather than
the national insurance increase which i
fundamentally disagree with
which places uh an extra burden
on the lower earners whose pay packets
will be
falling
this april at the same time as the cost
of living is soaring
so yes i think there is a case for
broadening
the base from which one takes
extra taxation clearly we need
extra public money to
invest and
shore up both the health service and
particularly social care which is still
being left out
but whether or not you should single out
the oil companies who we need i mean we
can see geopolitically
russia is threatening to cut off gas to
the west potentially
and
there is a real problem because of our
dependence
on
forms of energy that are not necessarily
controlled in this country and we need
to invest
in environmentally friendly energy
sources the best people to do that are
probably uh some of the bigger energy
companies
so
i don't i just don't think we should
single out one sector in particular okay
baroness altman uh fascinating thank you
so much for taking the time
thank you and you too thank you tamara's
um here talking about the um health
minister saying words have consequences
interesting yes and ros altman a
conservative peer said there's no doubt
the prime minister should apologize you
got the sense from ed argher the health
minister that he felt a bit uneasy about
it he wasn't defending the prime
minister he conceded words have
consequences and said it was appropriate
for the prime minister to have clarified
that's the word that tory mps are using
about this whole debacle that he didn't
mean sakirstama personally when he
accused him of not prosecuting jimmy
savile he was talking about the
organization that he led why does this
whole row matter a week on from when the
prime minister made those comments
because it has seen resignations from
his backroom team it has seen tory mps
who are weighing up whether the prime
minister is the man to lead them into
the next election wondering about his
character and judgment he changed some
of his team yesterday brought in a few
new people around him to try and shore
up party discipline but if this is the
tone he's going to take a lot of tory
mps don't feel very confident in it i
thought it was interesting that
yesterday mark harper an influential
tory described this whole savile issue
as grim and not the kind of country we
want to be as tory mps head off for a
week's holiday tomorrow i think that
will be on their minds okay thank you
thanks a lot tomorrow tomorrow's take at
nine o'clock of course um if you were
waiting to hear what was happening as
well as our hopes of a gold medal
in beijing our concern great britain's
hopes of winning that third gold medal
on snow were dashed there she is
charlotte banks originally living in
france now returning to the uk to take
part four team gb eliminated at the
quarter-final stage of the women's
snowboard cross in beijing
26 year old recovered from a slow start
to lead for much of the race but
apparently pushed wide on a bend
allowing um the oh she the australian to
move in and literally sadly she is out
now last year an international tribunal
found that china had committed genocide
against the uyghur muslims an ethnic
group native to the country's xinjiang
province now witnesses have told sky
news are being held in so-called black
sites abroad the existence of which is
officially denied of course here's tom
cheshire
the united arab emirates has been
rolling out the red carpet for china
over recent years
beneath the friendly diplomacy though is
a shadowy world one where chinese
security services operate on uae soil a
sky news investigation can reveal
hunting their targets
was detained in dubai last year after
she traveled to help a boyfriend who is
also being held
he was a teenager when he voiced his
support for the hong kong protesters she
says she was kept in a black site
operated by china
um
she was even interrogated by
high-ranking chinese officials on uae
soil
um
we was released after an international
outcry the fate of others is still
unknown
nigeria is also a uiga
so is her husband hussein
in 2017 he was detained in dubai
asked the uae turkey and interpol for a
response to our reporting i received no
reply
we also asked the chinese government
directly for a response to our reporting
he has disappeared into a world of
shadows
a world where china will continue to
operate
tom cheshire sky news beijing
now how do you sleep at night it's
probably nothing like this here we go
this clip has been circulating on social
media and shows cheetah cuddling up to a
man at a breeding center in south africa
now i think i'm right in saying that
cheetah don't have retractable claws in
fact you can see their claws there can't
you um yeah they're all snuggling in
yeah they could kill him like that if
they wanted to but obviously they are
very very as indeed very comfortable
dolph volker who films and studies the
behavior of cheetah that's him he says
it's natural for the animals who were
born and bred in captivity to share
warmth he didn't get much sleep though
as you can imagine
but it looks as though they did now take
a look at this rather beautiful
photograph love it love it love it
isn't that gorgeous image of two male
lion in the rain among the runners-up in
the people's choice award category of
the wildlife photography of the year
competition it's called shelter from the
rain
quite young guys aren't they not much of
a mane on there even with the rain now
another favorite from the category a
surprise encounter between a bear
and an eagle
[Laughter]
yeah i know who my money's on and this
was the one that took home the title
willows reflected in a frozen north
italian lake appropriately titled
lake
of ice how's that absolutely stunning
taken by the italian photographer
cristiano benderman who joins us now
hello to you cristiano thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
what a spectacular photograph tell us
the story behind it
good morning and
first of all let me say that i'm very
very grateful
and
so excited for
your invitation
today
um
i
i
can't believe i i won this award is a
great
success for me
lack of ice represents for me that the
closure of
uh
i always dream of being able to honor
the beauty of the lake
with photography of a good artistic
level
and uh
i would like to dedicate my
my my
picture to
a friend
who unfortunately passed away in 2018
and he always pointed out the
photographic potential of
santa croce arnie
he was a very good friend for me and
he always supported me and encouraged me
to
do my photography to
and i think
he helped me to win
uh he did it's an absolutely sensational
photograph we'll just have another quick
look at it and sharing it thank you so
much for sharing it with my viewers
right around the world this morning we
very much appreciate it thank you so
much for joining us on the program
stunning thank you so much
now new highway code rules were brought
in last week to make roads safer for
cyclists but it's unclear whether they
have had the desired effect with reports
of a growing number of clashes between
drivers and cyclists so we thought that
we would put it to the test howard cox
founder of fairfield uk campaign and ian
coma member of the surrey cycling club
are both with us this morning into you
first of all um has it made the roads
safer
i think any changes to the law that
tries to make the road safer it does but
today you know you have to look at it
and um i think at the present moment no
it's not because the reason being is
lots of drivers don't know the new rules
and think cyclists are just uh
obstruction to them in the road
howard what do you think
well ian's very right that we should be
the highway code any changes to the
highway code is welcome we want to do
that but this lady's highway code is a
cyclist chartered to drive any how they
wish no matter how dangerous without
fear of any prosecution i mean they seem
to be given what appears to be a legal
right to pass all the blame onto every
other road user and we're very worried
about this i mean the only widows will
be lawyers insurance companies and
undertakers and let's be clear i on
behalf of fairfield uk and 1.7 million
drivers really do want safer roads for
all road users but this particular
highway code we think is dangerous and
i'm backed by the road hordage
association and they really are worried
about the safety of cyclists because of
the changes in the highway code
ian
yeah um i think one of the points is
many many cyclists the road users own
drivers so we understand what you should
be looking out for we also have you know
the ability to um you know focus very
clearly on cyclists i think you know
some of the rules in place are really
good um you know examples of being able
to move into the middle of the road um
to prevent cars overtaking you in
certain circumstances where they can't
see round a bend that is a classic um
happened to me this weekend
i'm riding out this weekend a car
overtook us on the wrong side of the
road going around the bend he had no
view of seeing now not all car drivers
are like that and i understand you know
not all cyclists are going to really be
you know abiding by all the rules but i
think everybody has to
take note sit back listen read and
understand and one of the issues has
been the publicity around this in the
fact that it's been introduced but there
is been sort of a lack of public
awareness of the new rules and
regulations
yes i couldn't agree more with you and i
think you're absolutely right and i
think every household should be sent a
copy of the highway code but the the
issue is there's two or three uh rules
changes one is allowing undertaking
overtaking by cyclists from behind say a
40-ton truck which does have blind spots
it can't help but have it and we all
look out all responsible drivers and
responsible cyclists do drive and cycle
carefully but we can't cater but
unfortunately you do have a bunch of
militant cyclists uh that actually
unfortunately would they they're really
relishing the new changes and taking
advantage of the fact that they can
control the roads now and even when
there are cycle lanes now on roads they
don't have to use them it says on in the
new highway code and that we just don't
get this we want safer roads and he and
i i would love to work closely with you
to actually convince the government uh
that we should be uh working together on
road user safety
surely um ian if there's a cycle lane
that's what cyclists should be using
if it's suitable yes uh they're not
always suitable um and it depends on the
cycle yeah you gotta understand these
rules are for all cyclists you're
talking to a member of surrey cycling
club um yeah but rules are there for
people who cycle to work whose business
is cycling you know you look at the
number of um
delivery drivers now who use bikes so it
is uh the you know the the choice of the
cyclist whether to use a cycle lane or
in the road there's no rules to say i
can't cycle in a road uh even though
there may be a cycle lane there
yeah but why wouldn't i don't understand
why you wouldn't use the cycle lane
that's what it's there for
it just depends on the conditions of the
cycle lane um you know you have to you
have to take that into consideration
where the cycle lane is if i have to
cross the road to go onto a cycle lane
and then
cross the road again surely me crossing
the road twice
uh is potentially more dangerous than
just staying on the on the road that i'm
cycling on not all cycle lanes are
running beside the road not all cycle
lanes are on both sides of the road um
yeah and uh this would be one one of the
the you know the main issues is that uh
you know it's the choice of where these
cycle lanes are put um is it suitable
for a cyclist to you know dismount
across the road okay go the other side
and get onto another cycle okay good to
talk to both of you thank you very much
indeed for joining us hopefully we put
you together and then you can maybe
discuss going forward um how to help
both sides thanks very much indeed for
joining us thanks a lot
thank
you
i think they said thanks uh let's have a
quick look at these uh pictures uh
should we here um on the programme this
morning here we go
how beautiful
is that it didn't win but it was another
one of those wildlife pictures that we
were talking about in the competition i
think this is one of the ones where the
lake won you know with the with the
trees in it just been speaking to the
photographer who took that image and
have we got another one
not sure i understand that
i think it's what you call art and
finally
yeah i've got that one yeah who are you
looking at
how cute is that coming up in the next
hour here on the program we're going to
be uh reminding you what the health
minister has told me this morning he's
been talking about words having
consequences when it comes to what the
uh prime minister said about sakia
stammer and the savile slo what does
labour think of it all stay tuned for
more here on sky
[Music]